directeur général de la société de
transport de montréal pour quelques
temps encore bonsoir monsieur tremblay
bon sens ne se voit bon on va revenir à
la structure archaïque dans quelques
secondes mais d'abord la question
fondamentale
vous avez 43 millions dans le rouge
difficile puis vous voulez pas couper
les services comment vous vous n'aviez
plus de solutions pour résoudre cette
équation l'avant en fait non parce que
depuis de ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que la problématique ne découle pas
seulement de la pandémie on avait un
déficit structurel bien avant la
pandémie donc on a coupé année après
année pour équilibrer les budgets et le
message contenant voici de penser
pouvoir continuer à couper les dépenses
pour atténuer l'impact
majeur et que la pandémie c'est
impossible de faire sont peu plus on est
vraiment rendu au maximum donc il faut
revoir notre sortie du modèle financier
qui date de très longtemps ne plus des
mesures on n'a plus besoin de nous nos
ambitions l'un des gros problèmes de
scooters dont il faut faire quelque
chose il est urgent d'agir le reste
selon moi est d'après vous qui doit
payer plus ce monsieur tremblay le
client québec montréal les villes qui
doit payer plus je pense que c'est un
peu nos sources de fonds sont déjà très
diversifié est un peu la responsabilité
de tout le monde de transport collectif
c'est un service essentiel on a joué un
rôle essentiel dans la pandémie donc
c'est un peu à tout le monde un petit
peu à revoir le mode de financement il
ya toutes sortes de choses qui peuvent
être faites je pense que si on y met
l'épaule à la roue savait que la paire
débit va avoir une crise du changement
climatique qui va être encore le puits a
pas de vaccin pour pour la crise des
changements climatiques et je pense que
le transport collectif est là estime
peut rejoindre en gros donc si on y met
du sien je pense qu'on est capable de
trouver des solutions
si vous deviez demain le équilibrer le
budget ça se ferait qu' découpe de
service d'un sport mais c'est ce qu'on
veut pas faire parce que si je vous
oblige à acheter je tremblais coupé
équilibré cette année il ya des coupes
de dans le service mais même si on
pourrait pour faire pour le faire par
l'ampleur du déficit il faudrait mettre
de faire des mises à pied et 90% des
employés ont la garantie nommé pied à
l'asm se soit montré du coeur aussi donc
il n'est possibilité à mettre en place
ces choses là et on veut pas le faire
parce que par la pandémie et une
meilleur moyen de santé c'est de santé
pour protéger les gens sont maintenant
services a permis d'éviter qu'il ya des
éclosions dans nos réseaux il y en a pas
eu parce qu'ils avaient de la fréquence
et ça permettait de respecter le fameux
de m alors c'est pas une solution couper
le service d'autant plus qu'on va
reprendre un jour et ça va être
important de donner un bon service pour
sauver la planète comme je le
mentionnais plus tôt là ça c'est
important car ça va reprendre mais ce
tremblay est ce que dans les conditions
actuelles
on va se retrouver encore avec des
classes sardines avec des wagons bondés
des autobus bondé ci a pas de solution
trouvée bah évidemment si a pas de fonds
supplémentaires
l'époux de nouvelles sources on peut pas
développer le transport collectif et en
plus ce développement il faut s'occuper
comme toutes les infrastructures au
québec qui ont mal vieillit qui ont
manqué d'amour il faut les rénover et ça
coûte extrêmement cher donc c'est très
bien développer les réseaux qu'on veut
ça aussi il faut s'occuper des réseaux
actuels alors sa cause toutes sortes de
problématiques et ça bien aussi ajouté à
la problématique financière donc tous à
regarder il sera plus critique et
recommencez vraiment urgence d'agir en
la matière cri du coeur puis vous dites
monsieur tremblay moi je m'en vais je
suis capable la rtm qui me donne mon
budget
c'est l' agence régionale de transport
métropolitain qui a été créée il ya les
municipalités qui qui qui qui
contribuent québec contribuent les
clients contribuent pleine bourre donne
l'argent vous êtes cela n'a pas de bon
sens ça ne tient pas la route c'est
extrêmement difficile de travailler
comme ça vous savez vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure le dixième de ce thème si la
deuxième entreprise en importance au
québec donc gérer une entreprise cette
ampleur le canton contrôle procès devenu
son contrôle pas ses dépenses on
contrôle pas la dette et les surplus ça
devient mon sens extrêmement difficile à
faire il a et m avaient été créés
justement pour une des raisons pour
lesquelles avaient été créés c'est de
devoir assurer une pérennité du
financement du transport collectif
malheureusement s'attarde ça marche
ça marche pas ce goût des noms ça
fonctionne pas il faut vraiment revoir
ça c'est sa principale responsabilité
tout comme prioriser les projets tout
comme aussi faire en sorte de planifier
le transport collectif dans la grande
région de montréal s'est pas seulement
là estime qu'il dit tous mes collègues
des sociétés transport dans la grande
majorité sont du même avis il faut qu'il
ya des changements et on
que ça soit probable qu'on a on a
adressé chose avant que justement on
soit dans la relance et que je revienne
dans les réseaux c'est le bon temps de
le faire et de s'y attarder bon mais
vous entre temps termina vous êtes
jusqu'à pas
ça marche pas
évidemment c'est sûr que ça devient
extrêmement difficile mais il faut
comprendre aussi que j'étais dans la
dernière année de mon mandat donc on
fait toujours une réflexion je pense que
c'est raisonnable aussi de penser que
d'avoir une nouvelle voie moi ça fait 28
ans que je suis à la stm mutants comme
dg donc peut-être de reprendre un simple
comme un coach aura qui est peut-être
que le nouveau porte parole ça peut
aider et de faire en sorte qu'une
nouvelle personne qui avoir un plan
stratégique en 2022 donc d'amener une
nouvelle personne qui va faire la manche
concédée bonne aloi mais vous êtes de
bonne chance à nouvelles personnes faut
qu'il y ait d'autres sources de revenus
faut qu'on fasse le ménage qu'on
simplifie tout ça la rtm n'a pas de bon
sens etc etc vous écrirez votre
testament au prochain comme client en
fait refonte en profondeur du message
refonte en profondeur du financement
refonte en profondeur de la gouvernance
de la région de montréal je pense que
c'est essentiel encore une fois on va
pouvoir apprécier sauver la planète et
je répète pas de vaccin pour la crise du
changement climatique il a estimé
transport collectif pour faire une
grande différence pour le futur merci
monsieur tremblay en français